what we're learning tonight from a leak
from the Department of Justice to The
Washington Post that the special counsel
investigating Donald Trump the
Republican FrontRunner is now looking
into whether he committed wire fraud
okay so as his numbers go up the number
of Investigations multiply this one
appears to be related to Trump's
fundraising efforts between the 2020
election and January 6th of course this
is an effort to sideline the front
runner in the Republican Party while
they figure about what to do with Joe
Biden
meanwhile Trump is talking in a way that
nobody else is about the most serious
threat to this country which is nuclear
war a nuclear war that the Biden
Administration seems intent on sparking
through recklessness and truly crazy
behavior and then of course the second
greatest threat to the United States the
other thing you'd ever hear about is we
Yammer on about trans rights is the
decline of the US dollar and we
interviewed Donald Trump yesterday in
Florida and that came up here's part of
the conversation
Iran gets together with Saudi Arabia
through China
and China's taking over and China you
know I heard a couple of people say well
the dollar will never lose the dollar
standard are they kidding
China wants to change the standard the
currency standard
and if that happens that's like losing a
World War
will be a second tier country we'll
literally be a second-tier country if
that happens
now you're losing Brazil
you're losing Colombia South America
you're losing uh Iran you've lost it
you've lost Russia
and if you haven't lost them yet you're
going to lose them China's on the one
so China's God
then you see France going over no what's
going on we're losing if we lose our
currency that's the equivalent of losing
a World War
a currency is what makes us powerful and
strong
and this was Unthinkable during the
Trump Administration and if I saw macron
do that
I would have I would have called them I
would have said you know what no more
wine into the United States no more
champagne into the and I had that with
him you know I had Steve mnuchin a good
guy was unable to make a deal with
France France is very difficult I will
tell you yeah they're all difficult
because every country rips us off
but France is in particular very
difficult
and you probably heard what they want to
charge American companies substantial
tax to do business in France so I had
mnuchin working on it and other people
working they were unable to they called
me back
just for a couple of months they could
not do it I said let me have macron get
him on the phone I said listen I
understand you're going to tax American
companies for
doing business in France here's the
story
on Monday morning if you don't drop this
on Monday morning was Friday
I'm going to put a 100 percent tariff on
every bottle of champagne and every
bottle of wine that comes into the
United States of America
he says no no no that's not fair I said
of course it's fair you're charging
American companies for going to France
and doing business in France a very big
tax
so all of your wine very good wine but I
think we make wine that's just as good
all of your wine and all of your
champagne that comes in I'm putting a
100 percent
tax Zone that's it so good luck Monday
morning at nine o'clock
that was it I get a call back 15 minutes
later
uh we've decided we're not going to
charge American companies but you know
what happened
once I left now they're charging him
so the takeaway from the interview we
did with Trump yesterday lasted over an
hour was whatever you think of his
answers the conversation was about real
topics it was not about global warming
or systemic racism or trans rights it
was about nuclear war
the US dollar and its strength against
other currencies are trade balance the
things that actually Define a country
they told you he was crazy for all these
years but why is he the only one talking
about these things so subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight